We thought we'd pick it up a notch
by asking you some flaming hot spicy questions.
Okay.
We're going to start out mild
but then the questions keep getting hotter and spicier,
I think some flames are going to come up.
This is the first time we've done this, I'm really excited.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The Heat is On, here we go.
(audience applauding)
All right, what's your go-to song in the shower?
Okay well I actually do the entire musical score
from "Sweeney Todd".
I like to sing about serial killers in the shower.
I like it.
Okay, have you ever eaten something off the floor
that was like, well, past that five second rule?
Drew, I just moved and I ate a Skittle
that probably was in the couch for seven years.
(audience laughing)
Okay, name a celebrity
you might secretly stalk on social media.
I don't even know if it's a secret.
I don't know if he knows but
it's not actually James VanDerBeek,
it's his five glorious children.
I stalk his children.
They're the most beautiful kids I've ever seen.
And I can't stop looking at them.
I love it, have you ever peed in a pool?
The pool, the ocean, and occasionally the shower.
(audience laughing)
Haven't we all?
Right?
I mean, seriously, if you could erase
a project from your IMDb, what would it be?
If Meryl Streep takes "Matlock" off of her resume,
I'll take "Matlock" off of my resume.
That's what they call equal opportunity and fair game.
We all have "Matlock" on our resume by the way.
I was trying to think of one I would do.
There's a long, there's like serious five-year chunks
of some serious BCD level stuff I've got going on in there.
Okay, tell us something that you've done
that might be illegal.
Okay, I'm from Ohio.
In the 70, who was not smoking crappy pot
that somebody grew in their basement under like.
(audience clapping)
Okay, read us the last spicy text
you sent to your husband.
The spiciest recent one was
my husband texting me saying,
where do you keep the oven mitts?
(audience laughing)
And I'm like honey, the second drawer down
to the left of the stove.
(audience laughing)
I love this so much.
I do, I do, I do.
Okay.
37 years of marriage, so yeah.
I just, it's so cute and delicious I love it so much
and just so real and wonderful,
that to me is spicy.
Okay, what your husband's favorite part of your body?
My brain.
(audience clapping)
Yeah baby.
Okay and now our final burning question.
Which of your TV husbands is a better kisser,
Ray Romano or Neil Flynn?
I would say, let me put it this way,
because Ray is also married for a very long time.
I'll give it to Ray.
Perfect.
He's got a lot of practice
Safe, loving, and so wholesome.
And you and your husband better work,
like work on those oven mitts later,
and get them out and have some fun with them.
And thank you for doing our spicy questionnaire,
you're the very first person to ever do.
I am so honored that I was the premiere spice,
I hope you get someone
who has a little more interesting life for the next one.
It could never be and it will always be known
as The Patricia.
And thank you so much.
Thank you for joining us today.
And I had the best time with you.
Thank you, Patricia.
(upbeat music)